como miles de migrantes fernán halal
tenía un sueño llegar a la unión europea
por ello este kurdo iraquí compre un
vuelo de turista desde erbil hasta minsk
la capital de belarús desde allí junto a
otras personas en su misma condición fue
enviado a la frontera con la promesa de
un futuro mejor
vi las tres fronteras la lituana la
polaca y la bielorrusa en las tres
fronteras me golpearon me torturaron
sufrí mucho cuando quise volver a minsk
tuve que tomar un taxi que cobraba 200
dólares por persona
se durmió a la intemperie del bosque
fronterizo soportando las bajas
temperaturas desilusionado días más
tarde tomó la decisión de volver a irak
a través de un vuelo de evacuación
gubernamental
europa tenía el gran sueño de llegar a
europa pero ahora este camino está
completamente cerrado todavía hay rutas
de contrabando pero no es tan fácil como
la gente imaginaba la emisión de ondas
nadie vale la pena
mi mensaje a los jóvenes es que si
quieren ir a europa la vida es muy dura
y esa ruta está cerrada
otros migrantes continúan intentándolo
si bien la mayoría de personas proceden
de medio oriente también hay
latinoamericanos como este cubano que
llegó a ver la luz desde moscú rusia
aumente cuántos cubanos de aquí
siete y todos quieren ir a alemania
german
a cubano en cuba me arrestan este
domingo el primer ministro polaco
calificó la crisis migratoria en la
frontera oriental de la unión europea
como el mayor intento de desestabilizar
europa desde la guerra fría polonia
acusa mins de orquestar la llegada de
emigrantes lo que bruselas ha calificado
como un ataque híbrido como respuesta a
las sanciones impuestas contra el
mandatario bielorruso con los migrantes
más vulnerables siendo usados como arma
de presión política